The accelerometer is
an incredibly flexible and
intuitive way for
your user to interact with your game.
The accelerometer reports
the phone's acceleration in meters
per second squared.
So if the phone is stationary,
the only acceleration it's experiencing
is the acceleration due to gravity,
which is equal to about 9.8
meters per second squared.
Does this sound at all
familiar from physics class?
Now regardless of the orientation
used by your game, the accelerometer
data is reported as though the phone
is in portrait orientation,
with the positive z-axis
coming out of the screen.
That means if the z-axis of
the accelerometer is reading about 9.8,
the phone is flat on its back.
If the z axis is reading negative 9.8,
then the phone is resting on it's face.
If the y axis reads 9.8 then the phone
is upright in the portrait orientation.
Note we have tilted the phone a little
bit and the y axis is reading positive.
If we tilt the phone this way a little
bit, now the x axis is reading positive.
Libgdx allows you to pull for
accelerometer readings using gdx
input get accelerometer x, y and z.
We can compute the total acceleration
using the good old Pythagorean theorem.
Down here we're drawing
those red bars you saw, and
this is actually the horizontal bar.
Notice the x position
of the end of that bar
is being determined by
the negative y axis.
That's because we're looking at
this game in landscape mode.
And all of the accelerometer readings
are reported as though the phone
was in portrait mode.
Here is the vertical line.
And the end of that line is
determined by the positive x axis.
You'll get a hold of
this quickly enough.
But if everything is sliding sideways
in your game, this is probably why.